derrière fois françois cluzet ça lui a
porté chance c'était il ya exactement
dix ans ça lui a valu le césar du
meilleur acteur pour intouchable depuis
la terre entière nous l'envient tantôt
gentleman cambrioleur tantôt dresseur de
recteur cédant tirailleurs qu'on le
retrouvera sur nos écrans à l'automne
prochain mesdames et messieurs omar sy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous on se remarque bonsoir
antoine
vous vous souvenez de cette cérémonie il
ya dix ans exactement évidemment que je
me rappelle un quelle soirée j'imagine
que ce sont des moments absolument
incroyable qui restent gravés à jamais
dans votre esprit ça c'est sûr alors moi
je me suis je me souviens d'un petit pas
de danse c'était il ya dix ans
exactement
oui j'ai une certaine souplesse et sa
voix j'imagine que dix ans après non
peut-être fait un petit peu moins
partant pour ce genre carrément pas
partant du tout apparaît peu d'arthrose
de kilos en trop le temps est passé
quand le temps est passé un peu
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour vous
remercier pour ses dix ans passés depuis
l'élan que vous m'avez donné était super
donc j'en ai fait des pas mais pas des
pas de danse d'ehpad et pas avec vous
tous on a tous marcher un peu mais
depuis deux ans on a les jambes coupées
donc je voulais avec vous ce soir en
dire à tous les gens qui travaillent
derrière les images qu'on tourne et
qu'on projette aussi qu'on est avec eux
qu'on est là on est là la famille le
cinéma français est là on est là avec
vous pour vous et pour nous aussi voilà
on va continuer à faire du cinéma
ensemble parce que c'est ça qu'on sait
faire
et je voulais vous rappeler aussi que le
cinéma est une fête par exemple ce soir
pour moi c'est une fête d'anniversaire
et pour françois aussi c'est une fête le
cinéma elle commence ici cette fête le
soir des césar
alors on danse au verdon sénat salle des
sonars ouais ouais ça veut dire de ce
[Musique]
non
oh
quel kiff bull assure que j'ai tout près
par jan 10 ans il veut pas se leurrer
eh bien vous êtes prêts